[Music]
when i was about five or six uh we got
our first vcr and it changed everything
we got to watch movies whenever we
wanted so cool and uh we usually get
them from the library at the university
where my dad worked um but we had a few
that we owned and
one of them and they were all precious
because we didn't have that many but the
one that was the most precious i think
was superman three
definitely the most precious to me yeah
i that's true that was you you loved it
too but i watched it religiously well
and i was forced i liked it i i did but
i was forced to watch it almost you
because you watched you'd come home from
school i think before me and it was
always on you you were watching it every
single day i watched it until the tape
itself started to break the movie itself
started getting
snowy looking and eventually
it just stopped working all together
because the tape for our younger
listeners it degraded you just watched
it that and that it's there's something
kind of sad about that that no one will
ever
know what that feels like to love a
movie so much you watch it so often
that you break it
you know that's something that are
happening out in that
you're listening to life for sure i'm
your very nostalgic host justin long
life could be a dream
and uh with me as always is my superman
three loving
brother
christian i love that movie yeah god
when they so it's the scene where
specifically the the part you wore the
hole in was when because you'd would you
rewind it you'd keep rewinding it to
that scene where the good superman
fights the bad superman oh so cool i
think that was the beginning of the
breakage in the movie but it was it
makes sense that that would be the scene
annie you watched a lot too okay um
all right but uh
superman three i it's funny we were
talking about
technological advances um that would
that that have only
gotten obvious obviously they get better
all tech and technological advances by
their very by the their nature improve
things i think so like light bulbs last
longer and um
cars are more safe and airplanes are
more safe and yeah computer um you get
on the internet quicker now and you get
on the internet faster now everything
gets better and yet there is one
advancement that i think has gotten
worse which is uh and it keeps coming up
because we've been watching a lot of tv
lately so we've been watching tv on like
streaming things
and
it might be our wi-fi but for whatever
reason
it just seems like it works
so much less frequently than it used to
be where you can just press up the
remote and it's click and it works
before that as a kid remember the
picture
i'm sure you remember this the picture
quality of the tv was so much worse when
we were kids than it is it was grainy
and we had a tv our first tv that i
remember didn't have a remote that came
with it so you'd have to actually get up
off your ass and walk over the tv and
turn the knob and we had six channels or
whatever went up to 13
and some were fuzzy all the time
remember 13 was always funny
was like channel 8 was a version of abc
it was like a connecticut affiliate of
abc and you would go from seven and made
that noise like
yeah like when you turn the channel
think think so the quality wasn't as
good and you had to get up to change the
channel all you know pretty inconvenient
in retrospect however it always worked
unless there was a thunderstorm or
something the power went out that's true
otherwise it always worked and now
the picture is beautiful and the remote
is you can see every pore on everyone's
face but it so often cuts out constantly
i mean part of it is our fault because
we don't have cable
yeah i know we rely on the internet
which but we have like not good
we joke about it whenever it goes out
will christian have been watching this
show kings kings of pain
which is these two guys
it's on uh national geographic channel
which is our history channel history
channel sorry yeah two guys uh one of
whom is named caveman
uh he sounds like bill paxton or norbert
leo buds hopefully future guest and um
they just make uh
venomous
insects and snakes and stuff bite them
and they rate the pain it's crazy show i
can't believe it's a show i can't
believe we watch it
no it's hard to turn away but um anyway
we've been watching that in like it'll
right before you know they're getting
ready to give the scorpion's about to
sting and it's like oh my god just do it
man do it and it's like the climate
climactic part it'll just be like cut
cut out or like freeze or
and it happens so often that we just
laugh about this it's part of the
experience of watching tv now isn't that
crazy that like it's gotten to the point
we're like well we just have to accept
that if your shows will just i mean i
gotta say we could remedy it just by
getting cable i know but i know anyway
why are we talking about
tons of pain people getting bitten uh
well we were talking about superman and
like watching things like that um on
streaming services maybe hbo max because
our guest today
is uh one of the great
superhero epic directors he's one of our
biggest directors um period freeway
i know i know in fact he's got two
movies coming out uh we'll talk about
our guest today is
zach snyder
uh zach is somebody that's been on my
radar ever since i saw donna the dead
dawn of the dead with sarah paulie i
love that movie do you ever see that one
you've never seen that version with um
oh ving rhames sarah paul it's [ __ ]
great anyway you know ty burrell's in it
he's so good uh but anyway zach has gone
on to become yeah like we said a huge
superhero director and he has now
directed the ultimate in the dcu
the pantheon yeah it's uh justice league
which is out now on hbo max it's a
four-hour epic and it's his cut it's we
talk about how that happened but
basically just for some context uh the
original movie was he directed all of
the
footage most of the footage the original
movie of the justice league and then he
suffered a very uh
tragic family
event his his daughter unfortunately
took her own life and we'd talk about
that today um
and uh he had to step away from it as
you would expect and so joss whedon this
other director took over
and finished it and a lot of fans felt
like
it wasn't as good as what zack snyder's
could have been and they wanted to see
zack snyder's cut to the point where
they started this huge online movement
to
pressure this the studio i get warner
brothers into allowing zach to finish
the cut which he did and they gave him
i think 70 million dollars to add shots
and cgi and he shot an extra scene so
anyway we it's that it's in its of
itself is an interesting story uh we
talk about that he also has a really
another cool looking movie called army
of the dead that's coming out on netflix
um
which uh hopefully won't uh if we watch
it hopefully we'll be able to get
through the whole thing without it
pausing his cut of justice league yeah
it's out now on hbo max i'm excited to
see it i am too and uh the trailer looks
amazing
people
zack snyder is
like a god
in that
comic book
geek world right he is and so i sort of
it's not insulting to say geeks i don't
mean that you know i thought you're
gonna say god insulting to gods
to compare a mortal but is is that uh i
don't mean to be diminishing no like
like uh i know nerd is in vogue now it's
it's not insulting to call someone a
nerd now maybe that's a better term well
den of g there was there's a you know
our friend denim geek there's an actual
i don't think it's pejorative anymore i
don't think it should be but i don't
think it is it depends on the context in
which you say it if you i think like
anything else like any other
pejorative term like slurp potential
slur that's true if you you know um so i
we say it about zach and he says it
about those geeks very lovingly he's
very affectionate um when it comes to
them and they seem to be they love him
they love him so uh yeah we talk about
that and we also directed 300 everyone's
seen that movie right 300 watchmen oh
god he's dragging humongous hit movies
yes and he's got a very interesting
style i love his slow-motion style with
great with music um so i i sort of
expected that he was i had never met him
i thought he was going to be this kind
of well we could talk let's talk about
that yeah yeah yeah let's just cause we
don't know how it works that's true
that's true nor do you and you're about
to uh if you keep listening
when i sit down with the god of nerds
and geeks affectionately said
zack snyder
life could be a dream sweetheart
hello hello again you're booming over
we'll meet
[Music]
it's funny even like when things like
this happen there's just technical
technological snafus you can still glean
a lot about somebody's personality you
were so patient throughout that for you
know
you never know what to expect just
somebody who's done these big movies and
you're like
seems very patient and kind about that
so thank you for bearing with us oh it's
my pleasure you know i i
for 10 years i was a director cameraman
before i started making movies and then
the last movie i just did i shot i was
the dp and the director as well and um
so i do have you know
i have a lot of patience for the
technical aspects of it because a lot of
times i'm the one that everyone's like
uh
what are we doing what's happening
yeah so guys it's fine that's arm that's
army of the dead which looks army of the
dead yeah so cool dave bautista a friend
of the show former guest um is a buddy
of mine and he just said he had this a
bla i mean he
he loved working on it and he looks
great in it uh
what was it like doing that i mean it's
your first experience with i can't
believe this your first digital shooting
on digital yeah it was really
interesting i um
uh
you know
jared um
the guy who owns red
he uh is a buddy of mine and he you know
he knew i was kind of thinking about
making this small movie i was going to
go to south america i still plan on it
this summer um and making this movie
called horse latitudes which is this
teeny little
micro budget movie
and i was like i don't know if we're
going to be near a lab or how i'm going
to do this you know to process the film
and so he just gave me a camera and said
here's the camera you should mess around
with it
and so in the process i just
started learning the camera what had it
been about the red about digital that
you were kind of squirrely about i was
just a film guy and i just didn't i
wouldn't even have thought of it to be
honest it just didn't seem like a thing
but yeah i had this great experience
playing with the camera
and we went to do army i was like yes
absolutely let's try let's shoot it
let's shoot it with these cameras and is
that why you decided to go back to
shooting yourself to doing it on yeah
because there's a lot of things i wanted
to do with the lensing in that movie
that i didn't think a dp would go for
frankly
um
a lot of super crazy experimental stuff
like i shot the movie i i i don't know
if you know anything about lenses and
stuff i'm sure you do but for an example
the the i i found these japanese lenses
these canon lenses that were built in
the 60s called the canon dream lenses
and they're like consumer
canon consumer lenses
but they open to 0.95
the aperture opens to a 0.95 which is
incredibly wide open
the depth of field is super
crazy skinny
and so i was like oh i want to shoot the
movie with these lenses and everyone was
like no you can't these you can't shoot
them a movie a motion picture with these
lens these are crazy lenses what types
of shots would they have been typically
for like specialty shots use them i use
them for everything uh i use the
you just like it
it just creates this beautiful
bokeh that is insane and the depth of
field is so thin and just they're creamy
and it's just amazing anyway i'm that
you know now i'm just sound like a crazy
no but but anyway no no it's interesting
but i'm saying zach those lenses what
would they have been used
they were they were design well i mean
sorry i'm going to do a little dorky
history at the time the the leica not
deluxe which is the nut the leica
version of that lens there's a 50 mil
0.95
leica lens which is incredibly expensive
and beautiful and
edge to edge sharp and just this amazing
lens
and so
canon in response to that was like we
need a 0.95 lens
and theirs was at a much lower price
point and
not quite as sharp and a little bit
weird but so much personality the lens
is like this
every one of them is different i have
like
15 of them that i bought
um and we had to analyze each of them we
did this huge like we did like charts of
each lens and looked at the edges and
everything and then all those lenses
were rebuilt in cinema housing so we
could actually use them to shoot
but um [ __ ] but yeah so they they just
have this they were meant for consumer
they were consumer lenses
but
they were just like you know
yeah they were a little bit like i don't
want to say a knockoff but they were
just like
this kind of
more organic less german not to be rude
but a less german version it's okay
yeah accepts this yeah um there's no
there's no possibility that lens
wouldn't be sharp from edge to edge
right that's great
yes no no
never peris the sod uh so that's
something that a dp would have been a
typical
dp would have been
you know they would have cautioned
against or they would have thought
they might have i mean i don't know look
i have a lot of great friends that are
gta yeah are amazing and very
adventurous and willing to do anything
but um this case
the only problem with this is if you
shoot the movie at 0.95 we never put a
stop on the lens the entire shoot right
so the lenses were wide open for the
first week of shooting there was no
because they were they were actually
building the lenses for me for they took
them apart and re-housed them and they
weren't finished so we got the lens with
no iris in it at all so it's just a
piece of glass and so you couldn't put a
stop on the lens if you wanted to and it
was fine by me i was like you guys don't
need to put the i'm never going to use
it
but my focus pullers you can imagine you
know on a movie oh yeah the camera has
to be in focus so that's all
those guys and my guys did an amazing
job i thought the movie was going to be
completely
out of focus and i was ready for that
and it turned out to be quite a bit in
focus wow quite a bit
well quite a bit of it
and
are you at a point now zach where you
can say something like that to the
studio
in this case netflix i guess that you
want to do this somewhat experimental
technique
do they just do they hammond hall a
little bit are they like uh we wish you
wouldn't but you can
uh you know you don't tell them exactly
in the terms that i just told you right
you say it's gonna be really cool and
it's gonna be beautiful
and it's gonna like nothing they've ever
people have seen and that's how you sell
it not with these it might be all out of
photos i have this very
edgy yes
very experimental okay yeah yeah no i
say it's like super cool like oh my god
hopefully most of it will be in focus
yeah i don't yeah that's not i just i
don't know
and thank god my guys were so good that
yeah
it's it's it's very much in focus
yeah
for i mean it's out of focus when it
should be when it should be yeah well
i i remember thinking that about dawn of
the dead which um was such a beautiful
looking movie it was so there was
something so raw and
it it looked so organic it was almost
like um it felt a little like it could
have been from the 70s like one of the
romero movies it had a little bit of
that texture but um
also modernized
it's funny because when i made that
movie there was
um you know i had been a commercial
director for years and so like my style
was very slick
and you know i had been a dp uh the guy
who shot that movie was named leonetti
oh one of the best
yeah and matt said um about halfway
through the movie
he was like you know what zach just i
know just do what you want now they
can't fire you you should just
but
but
my point is only that
you know the studio had asked me about
like where are all those like slick
super slick shots from oh yeah
yeah and i was like yeah well this movie
didn't really seem this kind of feels
more like this you know like what we're
doing it's a little more
genre aware yeah yeah i wanted to make
it you know that was so that the visual
style matched
uh you know the sort of content yeah
yeah and it does they were like okay
okay yeah
yeah well i will wait and see uh it does
we were hoping for some more doves and
some more kind of you know like
slow-motion laundry or something
i don't know what what was the thing
what were the commercials so those
commercials had um i see you said it
said a slickness like a uh
a kind of
glazed i had done like you know
listen i had done every kind of
commercial uh a lot of super bowl spots
um i was you know a lot of car
commercials you know toward the end of
my my commercial career i
i'd done a i was really a
i was almost a car guy exclusively
um just shooting sheet metal in the
desert you know at sunset you know and
were you
at that point yeah yeah
for you but but it sounds like you like
that kind of stuff you like making
things you're into the style the
aesthetic um or were you like just
yearning to tell stories
well yeah i know i was always um
you know it's funny because in the
commercial world and and yes i did a
tons of commercials in europe um and
there were always be these weird little
cool little story movies yeah and it was
always super fun and um i love doing
that and then
you know back in the states you know you
would get the odd super bowl spot that
had like this kind of cool
you know
little zinger kind of cool thing i did a
lot of the budweiser
um you know clydesdale spots yes and
stuff like that
but but you know in the end
um yeah i always was really interested
in like what
what uh
what story so i was constantly
kind of going
to the studios and doing like i started
quite a while
into my commercial pretty early into my
commercial career i got an agent
and then we i would go on a lot of
generals uh-huh you know with the
studios
and i would say like you know
you picture yourself guys you know
like let me make you guys a cool movie
you know
i didn't know what i was talking about
but uh it was it was fun to try do you
like zombies
well i literally i had gotten swat you
know the swap member oh yes i was
supposed to do that ah
and uh
and then i fell out with them because
they wanted to make a pg-13 and i was
like i don't know how to do that
yeah
oh that
tougher
yeah well dawn of the dead was certainly
i mean if that were if that was your
calling card at the time that was um
certainly not pg-13 i mean there was
something that was the other thing
we had 300 as well so we had 300 that i
had been taking around and everyone said
no to
and then i was about to make swat
and they and then i quit the movie and
then dawn of the dead just kind of
popped up and i said yes i'll do it
oh wow was it were you a huge fan of
those like romero's movies oh yeah yeah
yeah i'm a huge huge romero fan i tried
and you know as best i could
um but that movie i really tried to be
as reverent as i could to the source
material and like you know there's a lot
of easter eggs in there in that movie
you know
romero
um
easter eggs in there yeah like and then
and then army came along because of uh
after i finished on i just had this idea
uh because i'd been so immersed in genre
that i said to myself like
what would be the most genre genre
freak out
and then i just kind of
came up with this idea for like
it's a it's a zombie plague that hits
vegas and they wall the city so that the
zombies are stuck
inside and then they have a and then the
government has decided to nuke the site
of to eradicate the zombies
and there's a small window before
they're going to nuke the city but where
they pulled pretty much everyone back
where a team of like
sort of zombie killers could go and take
the money from
you know
so it's like it's like a full
that is so cool so it's like a heist
movie meets uh apocalypse but it's like
you know it's got a lot of like escape
from new york and oh yeah you know it's
very much like
you know i i love the
those kind of hardcore genre totally you
know with weird little dark comedy
moments like i'm think i got to work
with greg nicotero recently and we were
both nerding out over
the thing we did together was a creep
show episode and it has to do with um
the original uh night of the living dead
and we recreated the set you would have
loved it it was like oh it sounds
amazing yeah it was like a movie nerd's
dream but um we were just geeking out
over those old genre movies and of
course he worked on so many of them and
i i love that [ __ ] and and your stuff
feels like it comes from somebody who
loves that and has like a real reverence
for that stuff oh yeah i absolutely do i
love like you know
and even like you know there's a lot of
like um
you know original terminator
aliens
those were your things all of that when
you were a kid
were you a superhero kid or were you
more like science you know it's weird i
mean i love star wars and then i kind of
you know i really got
like look i love
like john borman's one of my favorite i
love excalibur
but then also i love kurosawa so i even
as a kid i would go see like
i remember like my parents having to
drop me off you know to go see like
throne of blood or something
you know
they just had no interest in going you
know
this
japanese movie the samurai movie that's
like subtitled you know when i was like
in eighth grade you know they were like
wow
where did that come from do you think i
don't know i just was like so into it
and weird
it's just super weird yeah they were
just convinced my dad was pretty sure
that this was going to all end in tears
and then
i had no he was like well what's the
plan you know
a pretty practical guy you know he is he
worked at the american can company in
greenwich that's how oh oh wow and so
then he and then he moved over to
beckton dickinson
um
oh so he was like a serious business guy
yeah he's a you know he's and he's an hr
guy and he's very so he would just go
like so what
what are we doing like what's the
what's that i love your skt scores and
i'm a little concerned
the movies are cool fun hobby but it's a
great hobby i see what you're doing with
your friends wow and it was a little
like you know it was a little bit of
like uh
a little bit of rushmore you know
around our place i remember in high
school the big one of the big films i
made was like it was kind of like a
remake of apocalypse now but like set in
my boarding school
and so you know there was a lot
there was a lot of like farts of
darkness yeah it literally was hearts of
darkness i remember i got the greenwich
police department to come to the school
and on like volunteering for the finale
you know arrest the like protagonist
during the scene and they were like okay
you know
oh that is cool yeah those are like yeah
like the place he's putting on that's
yeah that's fine
yeah so i was doing that and uh
and uh
my dad was like no no i don't i'm not
i'm not sure about this so was your was
your ambition to actually do it do it in
life was that did did you have to kind
of sit on that i i yeah you know not to
be i wanted i also had ambition to be a
fine art painter that was my other thing
i wanted to do so i went to school in
london for a year huh and i started
painting at this school called hedley's
and then from hedley's
i went to art center here in pasadena
which is right actually just a mile away
from my house here oh wow
and um was he okay with that was that a
path that he was like okay i think when
i went to art center he was into it
because he saw that art center was one
of the top art schools in america
ah he was very like he went to williams
i don't know oh i love him i do a lot of
plays up at williamstown yeah yeah he
went with himself you know i i didn't
have a chance on earth of getting into
williams there was like no yeah there
was no world you know i i've always ever
like sometimes i've wanted to go and
teach a class
up at williams just just so i could tell
my dad like oh yeah they invited me up
to teach a class you know an honorary
professor no big deal yeah
yeah then he would be like oh my god
like finally yeah i'm kind of awesome
he's coming stupid zombie and caped
crusader movies exactly although i will
say he's he's the proudest
of like you know don't get near him like
at an airport
or anything like in the dmv line because
you will hear my entire career okay
everything
my parents are good at that too and
they'll bring it up somewhere they'll
find some roundabout way of getting to
it you know i've seen them do it
yeah i'm sure they're like so um
when you were talking there it sounded
like you were doing a little bit of
acting you know what i mean like i'm not
100 sure what what you were saying was
true but it did sound a little like
acting you know what
how did you imagine it
i saw you at the water fountain there
drinking some water you know who doesn't
need water as zombies
um
yeah exactly it's actually like that man
my dad's like so you but he'll go like
so you like do you like movies like say
that to someone yeah pretty good that's
pretty easy in there now that's pretty
uh
so it's really generic in yeah super
generic like i guess i like movies
i don't know where you're going with
this yeah i'm happily married i should
tell you
uh so when you were so at what point was
he like uh well zack i guess it's you
know i'm at what point did he kind of
accept what you were doing that it was a
legitimate thing to be doing
yeah i don't know i i think like a
little a little bit into my
i i mean the good news is i when i got
out of school i pretty much went
straight to work
oh wow you know as a direct commercials
on commercials yeah i got out of arts
center i graduated in 1991
and i went uh
i had about maybe six month period where
i was kind of looking for work and then
i got signed
by um a little commercial production
company
um and i started making movies or
commercials um
sorry to interrupt
i had a bunch of spots that i had done
at art center on my website oh okay and
one of the things about art centers they
trained me
they trained us really well kind of to
get a job
out of school which is hard for film
school you know it's like
yeah you know
so i had these cool um
i think i had about six tv commercials
on my reel that i had produced and
written oh that's great right so smart
so it wasn't like it's funny because one
of them was an ad for hbo
there was a i did an hbo campaign
you know weirdly i have a show coming
out at hbo
max you know tomorrow
tomorrow justice league well now it's
out now actually it is out now well
technically oh yeah of course it is
outright schneider's justice
league
zack snyder's justice league yeah well
it's funny because so i yeah so hbo
weirdly um one of my first
you know commercial spots i did for
myself i did this thing called it was
the campaign was called release yourself
from the bonds of network television
that was the campaign and it featured
uh three there was three different
commercials one was samson
like
like being like
like chained to these two columns super
stylized this big muscular guy these two
columns with his eyes put out you know
you know kind of like
you know crushing the slow-mo crushing
like 300 stars and then one was like a
joan of arc character being burned
at the stake
you know
it was really cool and um
gosh i can't remember the third one
someone being someone being everyone
being chained is all about breaking the
chains oh that's cool yeah freeing
yourself yeah super stylish and i did
get
off those spots i got um
a nike commercial
for uh wimbledon
when i was inside and that's kind of got
me going and i also had done
and then i was doing a bunch of music
videos like i did a morsi music video oh
cool um
that was great i love morrissey i did a
um
uh paul westerberg
i did
i was doing all these like really cool
kind of uh
buzz mtv buzz clips you know like yeah
did you do runaway train yeah no i
didn't do uh i didn't do runaway train i
said somebody to shove that was the one
i did oh yeah which was on that thing i
love runaway train i want to be here
yeah
oh sorry i brought it up no it's okay it
hurts a little but it's fine so i can
see it's still wrong
you must have been young zach you must
have been like a like yeah right now i
was like literally it's like i graduated
from college like oh my god god
and where and you're known i know a lot
of people not to reduce you to this but
one of the styles that you really
helped popularize and made i mean it's
yours it's like a signature styles
that's slow that great slow-motion stuff
where were you doing that where did that
come from that kind of style that that
uh we now associate with you
i think it came frankly from my canon
1014 xls super 8 movie camera i was
going to guess that sorry to know the
name of it that's yeah that's weird
anyway the camera
it's a canon camera
and it has on the side of it a slow
motion button so you can set it in slow
motion or you can push the button and it
actually ramps to slow motion and when
you take your finger off it goes back to
normal speed again that's cool it was
just a feature i don't know if anyone
used it for anything except for me when
i would film the fight scenes between my
neighbors in the backyard i'd constantly
be going
oh my god
god that's cool
in the early 2000s millions of
households across the world tuned in to
watch contestants battle for the last
rose or to be the final survivor on the
island reality tv was beginning to
dominate the airwaves and every show
needed to be bigger flashier more
scandalous than the last but in the case
of one infamous dating show the real
drama was happening off-screen and it
would shape the future of reality tv the
reality tv series there's something
about miriam seemed like a pretty
standard dating competition six young
men vibed for the affection of miriam
rivera a beautiful model from mexico but
when miriam revealed that she was a
trans woman during the show's finale the
on-screen drama sparked an international
uproar about gender sexuality and
whether reality television had finally
gone too far follow harsh reality the
story of miriam rivera on apple podcast
amazon music or you can listen early and
add free by joining wonder plus in apple
podcasts or the wondery app
[Music]
hello hello again
[Music]
i'll never forget seeing watchmen for
the first time i got outside of the arc
light um and god the way you use music
that that's great i mean uh times there
are changes
yeah oh [ __ ] was that powerful and the
slow motion stuff and those shots were
uh there was something so stirring about
that um i'll never forget but that was
the first time that was my
i couldn't believe it's the same guy
because it was different it felt
different stylistically than dawn of the
dead it didn't feel don the dead seemed
more frenetic and yeah and i think that
had a little bit to do with the fact
that you know dawn was like hello it's a
low budget movie you know right right
and i was
sort of you know
it was it was a
it was a
labor of love and we yeah and at that
time i was drawing all the shots i just
wasn't showing my book to anybody
i have a dawn of the dead you know
because i draw my own storyboards right
oh so
i was drawing dawn but like i would you
know i didn't know that that was a way
to do it you know
say hey everyone look i drew the scene
yeah matt lee would be like why are you
showing me that yeah like are you
serious but then by the time
i got because then i had done 300 and
really drawn everything and then when i
got to watchmen i really
i had
a sort of a system and like where i
would draw
i'm supposed to do digital
animated storyboards ever at that point
i had not really i mean i just it was
more of like the i have these big
leather bound books that just have all
the drawings in them you know they're
like volumes and i think that so the
design part of it on watchmen was much
more
deliberate you know yeah yeah everything
was very like i was like okay
you know that easter egg this yeah thing
you know it was all
everything had a meaning and like there
was nothing by accident
uh-huh you know there was a bit of that
in dawn but we were just on a
budget you never running gun yeah
um i'm i'm not picturing mattley and
eddie i cuz i've worked with him on a
comedy once and he was always like
uh yeah
he he's he'd come he'd say things
sometimes that were like you guys
finally did something funny you know or
like he'd be like
because he was you know yeah he's right
yeah now he's he's tried yeah
but whenever we make him laugh we were
like oh like even just to get a smile
from lee that was fun then that guy
we did it we nailed it the one time i
don't know the rest of this movie's
gonna work but that yes one joke for
sure totally it passed the leonardites
um
yeah how um so so was your were you
really into like picturing like 70s that
was what a great time for super hero
first like superman and richard donner
stuff and and then um were you really
into those movies or more of the comic
books were you a christian i i was uh
you know i cut my teeth sort of in the
in the sort of learning about graphic
the graphic from a from a comic book
comic book
well it's a uh it's an adult illustrated
fantasy magazine called heavy metal
um and it was um
it was a
it
basically like an anthology
um
and it was sort of uh
you know you would get it and it would
have different vignettes a lot of
european artists would draw on it and it
was like it was a comic book but it
wasn't really a comic book yeah um and
it was adults so there was a lot of sex
and violence in it and um
my mother got it for me by accident i
had gotten a copy of it
uh and i was like you know whatever 13
or 12 years old and i remember my mother
saw it and she just saw the cover and it
looked like
on this particular episode there wasn't
like a naked woman there happened to be
just like a robot
so she was like oh he loves this
and then out of the kindness she got me
a subscription
oh man without ever looking at the
inside and i was like thank you mom
that's that's really great and so i just
it was hard to go back to a normal comic
book because like when are those two
when are they gonna start having sex
um
i'm just flipping through and i'm not
i'm not yeah i don't see it
yeah
yeah there's something somebody must
have taken some pages out of this yeah
robin's this is not where
this guy never gets decapitated in the
thing i don't know how yeah so i was
like a little bit broken by that i think
but neither huey dewey nor louis ever
get uh impaled on anything yeah why
aren't they like
i think a love scene between the three
of them would be amazing
really funny that she did it out of um
if she had found out like what was
actually
at all she was like she was very
bohemian kind of uh right you know she
was pretty um
she's pretty liberal in her sort of uh
she didn't like to police us
from an artistic standpoint you know
right she'd always be like you know yeah
you're a genius we got a lot of you're a
genius
i kind of i was kind of pretty sure like
she didn't know what that word meant
kind of threw it around
i was like i am not sure
that that's really good yeah she'd go
through the toe booth and get the proper
change you're a genius yeah i'd be like
oh great now yeah or i would draw the
worst drawing ever in retrospect she'd
be like
that needs to get framed and like right
oh that's really sweet yeah it's really
sweet i mean i think that from that
standpoint
you know because i just i did have this
like i wasn't let's just put it this way
you know there's that whole thing of
like
you know you
the job you want you want to be a movie
director right that's what you that's
your that's the job you're saying out
loud to people
that you want that you want right
and it you know
in retrospect i uh
i
i remember
um i won't say who it was but i ran into
a um a guy who directed films
he was the um
he was the uh
father of uh someone i knew
and
i remember and i was in like really it's
like my first year in college
and he was like you know because not
everybody in film school wants to be a
director you know like some people
editor or whatever and remember i met
him and he said um so what are you
interested in and i said i want to be a
director
and he goes who the [ __ ] do you think
you are you know i was like what like i
didn't know i didn't know i had like
touched a nerve you know he was like
jesus
you cocky little son of a [ __ ] oh my
god you don't know what the [ __ ] you're
talking about you're gonna like you
think you're just gonna be a director
like what kind of [ __ ] ideas do you
have you know it's like i was like
and i was like oh god i didn't know uh
i didn't know that was a
i didn't know it was a problematic
professional tell me it wasn't frank oz
or something
but in the end i just like it really was
a little bit of a wake-up call to me
going like
yeah my you know
is this hard
is it
oh no you're just gonna do your film
school and then go make your movie yeah
you become a hit director yeah that's
funny
his reaction was just like i because
he knew how lucky and how much he had to
struggle and was like was that the
arrogance he thought you were just
arrogant i think so i think that's what
it was that it was a big like i was way
too cavalier and tried
to to relax about this thing i didn't
say i i'm hoping in the future
if everything goes right you know and
and and the stars align
right you just set it up properly
realize now that that is what happened
i got incredibly lucky and the stars
aligned and the right guy broke his leg
and couldn't make it to the meeting yeah
and clearly there was like one of the
people that said yes to me was probably
too busy to say he was a confluence of
very lucky yeah yeah yeah yeah i know
that now
but i didn't know it at the time thank
god and you may have i mean
that's why just
from your your parents point of view i
mean it's what what a good thing they
did for you that they that they did
brainwash you in that way that they
didn't
uh give you any you know they didn't
instill any fears or like you didn't
feel like you felt like it was
a possibility that uh i did i must have
been i did yeah i honestly did i thought
um
at no time did i think
um
you know
i was like okay should i be a painter or
a film director uh-huh i didn't okay i
wasn't delusional i didn't also think
like maybe i should be a model or a or
like an astronaut too i'll keep those on
back burners you know should i be a
center for the knicks or a tight end for
the eagles
so happy maybe i should be a pro athlete
that would be cool they're gonna do that
later i'll do the movie and they're
right
jumping once i don't i don't have the
youthful energy to direct anymore i'll
go ahead and become a professional
athlete
no yeah so i wasn't i wasn't completely
insane yeah i i do thank them though for
not
you know
maybe being 100 realistic with my dream
because nice yeah i'm pretty sure
you know i have
i don't really have any measurable
skills other than this so it would have
been difficult if this hadn't worked out
i don't know where you know
what i would be i think the same thing
exactly not about you but myself yeah
i'm like thank god i i am
uh do you ever run not about me but i
get that if you did it would be fine
i had that i like it you're like i have
that same feeling but you could be a
zoom
right uh about i could be with you i'm
not assumed technician do you say zoom
technician yeah yeah maybe
yeah maybe a sound guy i don't know yeah
um
because sound guys are amazing so i'm
like yeah oh no no no yes yeah yeah
have you run into have you run into that
director uh since
since then your friend's father i have
not i have not oh man i mean i i don't
know that he
i don't know that he knows that that
it's going okay
oh right it'd be funny if he was still
like that eric he still thinks he can do
it he hears you on some interview and he
looks at this guy yeah oh okay you
direct 10 little hits and you think you
can be a director
i know i don't know it's uh
it's funny look you know the truth is
that like i've always been
you know
in in
in my career you know i've always been
of the mindset that
i don't know i i i just i really i value
everyone's opinion so much
that you know sometimes it's a detriment
you know as a director oh man but
sometimes you know
i always just i my knee jerk is that i
assume that everyone kind of has a
better idea about
what's happening than i do you know so i
always have to kind of like you know i
don't make the i don't i i try not to
assume that
except for
and you know it's the thing i've talked
about like the only thing as a movie
director the most important skill set
you have is like your point of view you
know like
what
the sort of premise of making a movie is
that you guys have agreed
in a way
to sort of
hear hear it from my point of view yeah
yeah
and yeah and and and i would never argue
or ever say like
that what i'm saying is right
necessarily it's not okay god it's not a
that that's not the game we're playing
like that's not some measure the measure
is like correct right the correct scene
is right right right
yeah i mean a comedy is exactly the same
way there's no
like
it's like
all the pieces are in play constantly
just they kind of how they fall is it's
not if they fall the right way they have
to fall in a way
totally and and the same actor can do
the same scene almost identical to
another
like steve martin and some not as
comedic actor could do the same sort of
thing and it would be
you wouldn't really be even be able to
just explain why one works and one
doesn't it's just
it's just through that lens through that
mouth the the the cadence uh for
whatever reason it's become special
instead of just like yeah
um
that's fine and maybe it was like yeah
was it a subtle raise of the eyebrow was
it like right his head tilted like i
don't know but that's hilarious
right i know i know well zach that must
be a difficult especially when you're
directing these big you know movies that
everyone that people talk about on the
internet that must be
considering what you just said
do you ever get like um
how do you do that i mean how do you
navigate those waters of people talking
about this stuff and having an opinion
and i i i well that's what i've been
lucky um i mean like for instance with
justice league i mean just this
whole thing that's happened with the
movie and that
this giant fandom like said no we want
to see it your way like we were right
that is cool
we want it that way with whatever
you think is cool we're into that that's
what precipitated this all right it was
just a bunch of people wow wow they just
all got together and said no we don't
accept
the non
you're the non version of that you just
do we wanted your version
the army of the nerds the
yeah and i and i thank god they're on my
side like they'll be on the wrong side
of that i well i know that's yeah maybe
that's why it's
it's a lot easier when they're on your
side and they're powerful they're vocal
and yeah well i mean look at you know
not to be too but like
after i made batman vs superman
and and there was you know the sort of
the gatekeepers were different
then you know that was
you know
uh
2015 i think right it's like any cool
news and like yeah and those gatekeepers
decided yeah i think we're in a
different time now where the gatekeepers
it's been
aggregated a little bit more you know
there's a lot more
it's almost more diplomatic yeah it's a
lot it is so like but those guys those
same guys they the studio were like
they've rejected you you have to like
talk to the bloggers and you have to
like get them to like you and bring them
to the set show them that you're making
it funnier you know so like i did this
dog and pony and i hated it and i was
like this is worse i don't mean this is
like i'm insane i'm like not sincere
like that's like i mean i don't like if
you look at justice league there's all
these easter eggs i put in the movie
um
that are they're like fountain head
references and i don't know like i don't
know if you know the book but you're
going to be directing that right and
well i i i don't know that we're doing
it anytime soon i said like you know
listen it's a book that's so politically
charged that i'm like we need a more
liberal government to do fountainhead
like you know
so everyone just could like not freak
out you know yeah you might as well like
remake mineconf or something yeah i just
to me it's like you know i if you're a
film director
you sort of understand
if you're looking at it through that
lens
building a building and making a movie
are very similar
things you know like you're always
you're making little compromises
constantly right so it's like oh you
know like maybe one story less would
still be good you know maybe does it
really need all that
those fancy window frames what if we
just made the windows you know like it's
always like
yeah yeah yeah
you get like a little imagine you end up
with like a little like i guess it's a
house you know like that that's yeah
and so for me that's what fountainhead
always was you know and i know that
you know for a lot of people it's a big
political thing but for me it's very
much about that but it was funny because
like
after those guys left
uh the
the set i put all these like sort of
references to the fact that you know
we would always say like we're howard
rourke but we just we said yes we we we
we we compromised we said
[Laughter]
that's real you know like that's the
reality but sure at the same time i'm
subversive as a kind of
you know i'm slightly passive aggressive
and so i just kept sort of shooting my
own stuff at the same time
and that's what allowed
us to have justice league kind of the
way it is you know oh oh oh so you were
like four-hour version
so you thought event so so the plan was
and i know
you oh you didn't i don't i mean not
that
not that you would eventually get to
recraft it and do that but but what that
you were going to you you must have shot
it i hope you i thought that
cooler heads would prevail eventually
right
right and that if i had the material i
could show it at least and
you know
and i knew like a lot of the jokes i
could cut out that i didn't think were
funny and you know so i would just like
well i would i just did a lot of it
it's such a giant movie that you know
you're you're literally like
the head of a corporation when you're
yeah right so it's like
you know this product has to appeal
to
you know infants
and also right you know
as a commercial director you you have to
know that
yeah and it's funny because like in
commercials i'd always be like how much
do you want me to care about this
yeah yeah you know like because it's
true like how much do you want
like because if you want me to carry 100
i'm going to make it in black and white
uh-huh like no they're like no no that's
too much caring
oh okay
much less caring yeah much less scary
okay color all right you're on to
something i like that
how about
it's like at in this kind of like really
kind of reflective dark no no no no no
less caring okay outside
okay we like that you know
slowly turns into like the thing that is
the least offensive we're going to use
total unknowns care less leblanc yeah
yeah i think that like that's the
that's the process you know the
compromise process and compromise
process and so like you know
you can fight that
as hard as you can
and that's kind of what we
so
god you know zach you remind me so much
of you must know him sam raymond you
must know and and i only met sam once
but uh yeah oh man he's a great guy
great guy and you both grew up making
little movies with friends there's so
many parallels that i'm sensing and he i
remember him saying that i'm a huge fan
of his movies by the way
oh yeah he got me
oh yeah when we were doing that he said
he had just come off the spiderman
movies and i remember him saying he
compared it to like conducting these
symphonies where he would ride around
i'm sure you can relate riding around
the golf cart like approving this second
unit thing and then you go to another
whereas this he said he's like sir it
feels more like a like a string quartet
like intimate and i'm playing in the
sandbox again and you're talking about
doing that movie in south america i'm
sure it has that kind of appeal to you
and that was a great that was the joy of
army was yeah really just me and and
john my my k
my a camera operator and i we both just
were like
crossing and it was awesome just to like
yeah you know just to try not to film
each other you know that was funny yeah
you know
trying to get his clothes up i'd be
trying to get mine and we'd be like
framing each other out and then ah like
yeah i bet and so now do you feel like
all those compromises you're talking
about in terms of like people showing up
and having to appease this group and
that
does is the um is your cut now the zack
snyder uh justice league
is that just fully your version are you
now able to just do your thing that's as
much my version as i could do with what
i shot and i'm very happy with it don't
get me wrong i'm not there's no caveats
um
it literally
but
the nerds are ready
i know no caveats it's it's it's it was
it was an amazing experience to put that
movie back
um
and make it you know it's like what it's
never happened before
and i don't know that it'll happen again
like the circumstances
you know
with what yeah we went through as a
family and and the whole thing and
i just think that there's just
to sort of try and
regain although the fans were saying
they want to see like we've talked a lot
about a movie
um like a movie of this
they want bradley cooper to play me i
thought that was
like obviously it made a lot of yeah it
does it's not you don't have to
you know i was like
i mean
we might have to like pretty him up a
little bit for it
right he'd have to work out a lot yeah
he'd worry about working out a lot of
games no but i was
laugh
get sword michael's orchid to write the
script you know well would it make um do
you think it would make it a compelling
movie i mean like you're joking about it
but like it sounds like it might
actually be they're doing one about the
godfather it is not
i mean look they made
social network into a movie i don't know
if anything happened in that movie
really
trust me a lot happened
yeah a guy wanted to judge some some of
his college girl uh some of his fellow
college students
yeah on the internet i mean it's a good
movie i mean i'm not saying it's a great
movie it's a great movie yeah um so i
don't know but i'm just i am partly
joking i hope i'm joking but you know
netflix no do it that's like it's yeah
but now i'm picturing who would play you
because that's that's always one of our
questions we're about in fact we should
get to it soon uh our lightning round um
uh and i almost said army hammer and i
was like well maybe he's he might be
busy right now um
i uh
i i i the the movie is it must also just
be so fulfilling i mean in so many ways
you mentioned what your family went
through and and just just being able to
imbue some of
that experience into it and and um
just as a way to help
i would imagine process everything that
went on no it was incredibly cathartic
and um we really all did a lot of
healing through this process
and i and literally
the fans
have become
a lot of the fans have really become
you know you're not supposed to do this
but they're they're now friends of mine
and you know you know like that
and they're really like
you know i i do have like
and
a you know like there's a core group of
them that like literally
are amazing and they've raised so much
money for suicide prevention and mental
health awareness it's unbelievable and
they never tire and they're and they're
just
you know they have normal jobs and
they're like
on the phone with me in the middle of
the night just trying to figure out the
fundraiser
and that's amazing and it's just
incredible and i can't it's
i i like i go i hope you guys like the
movie because yeah
yeah so it's a lot of pressure you know
yeah for sure and now this added
personal pressure you're it's like oh i
hope my friends like it yeah i don't
even know
it's yeah it was really difficult you
know i dedicated the movie to my
daughter
and really i mean i'll be 100 honest
that i was worried
you know that the movie just wasn't good
enough you know i was really it was a
thing that really
struck me a lot that i was like maybe
this movie isn't good enough for this
but she was like also
our most
um she was my most
sort of fan centric child
um my other kids aren't really into the
movies and so i just felt like she would
really have she would really have loved
it so it worked it worked out
so it was cool um i mean i've read what
your friends on the internet have said
about it and it sounds uh
like a really beautiful tribute and i'm
my heart really broke for you zach to i
read about
when i read about what happened i'm
so sorry
[Music]
um
and uh
you you shot one new scene uh for
justice league yeah you attempted to
shoot more was it was the process of was
it was it
mostly just a matter of recutting stuff
and and why did you need that scene what
was it about that scene you know i
wanted to do this um
this
i just felt like if this is the last
movie i make in the
dcu um
it just felt rude
not to have had joker and batman meet
because
they're kind of
you know they complete each other
yeah use those terms um who is that i
hope that's in the scene i think he says
who who's gonna give you a reach around
is literally what jared says and i think
that it's it's a good question it's a
it's a valid question i think which
is
yeah who else can reach your cod piece
yeah it's like literally i come on
yeah so it felt it just felt
you know if you put it in those terms it
felt it feels rude not to not defeat you
so yeah so that was the real that was
the catalyst for i just wanted to put
those two together i had questions about
what they would do when they saw each
other and so it was it was fun to do it
um and of course you mentioned the
people that you whose opinion
their opinion matters and i would
imagine none none more so than
christopher nolan and a lot has been
made about this about how nolan told you
not to watch the first justice league
and all that um but why
why do you why do you trust christopher
nolan no um
i'm turning to jiminy glick um
that's good batman versus superman who
wins um
what
why can't they tie
what um
what what what did that feel like when
he said that and like yeah a guy that
you must trust more than anything well
you know he you know debbie my wife and
chris
uh my wife who's my producer um yeah and
chris who was also a producer of the
movies also producer justice right yeah
it was uh
it had fallen to them to go watch the
other version
uh-huh
and uh they just came back and we're
like uh
yeah you never need to see that yeah you
might
you might you might become a disgruntled
employee or whatever you call it like oh
my gosh
like well i am they were afraid they
were afraid for a second i was like well
the other thing about this about getting
to recut this is like just
creatively it's like oh man you go
through i can't imagine
uh shooting as much as you shot in the
work that goes into that i i i made a
little movie with my brother a year ago
and it's small small and that took a
solid year of our lives and and
so i can't imagine just the time that it
must have taken so to be able to now
have something
anything but something that you're proud
of to show for it must be like oh it's
really it feels good it really does
and i'm just so happy and i'm happy also
for the fans who love these characters
yeah to like really be able to take a
deep dive with them you know yeah and
also you know just the trilogy now if
you use the the batman um the the the
batman versus superman uh ultimate
edition which is like you know the
director's cut of that movie that's a
solid three hours and then uh
justice league is four
so uh
so if you have a free week
the the trilogy is nine hours now so
it's pretty pretty it's a pretty good
it's a pretty good little world if you
really want to go
yeah yeah it'll be cool to see that one
day i go to the i mean when i can't wait
for theaters to reopen that even though
you're in one now yours hasn't closed um
where available going to play all three
imacs because i did complete an imax
version of justice league i have and so
our plan is in the fall
all the fans to get together and do like
a weekend like a universal city walker
somewhere with a giant theater and
everyone just flies in from all over the
world all the hardcore fans and we just
do all three movies and just oh okay
nuts
and and where can people donate uh zach
in terms of afsp uh i if you just uh go
to the uh afsp's website you can donate
an autumn snyder uh family fund if you
want to donate directly to
our our fund um
but uh yeah or anywhere anywhere frankly
that's great but anywhere you want to
you know anything
you know it's not hard to do outreach
for mental health or suicide prevention
i don't want to you know there's a lot
of organizations all of them valid so
if i if you want to give it anyway
please
[Music]
what is your most commonly used emoji
would you say if you use winky face
yeah just the one
because it's kind of like really i used
to kind of like because i always get
these questions from fans like is there
going to be a
this in the movie
you know i've always liked wiki
maybe i don't know what it means exactly
but it's good
right it colors it it's like so they
can't take it too seriously
they can't run with it you can't run
with it but you're kind of like i think
you said yes it's a lot it's a lot of it
it
it'd be funny to see now that i'm
thinking about it to see that quoted in
like some
cinema
magazine some source you know said
he said
yeah yeah
um
if you could be a uh a professional
athlete what sport would you play
um
i probably uh
well were you a jets giants
you know i i come from the super
athletic family we play a lot of sports
my son played football you know all
through high school and
you know he he you know he went to ucla
played football there he didn't oh no
but yeah he's like
and uh but i i think i i'm a badminton
player uh i know that sounds not but i'm
on us the the olympic badminton uh us
olympic badminton uh i i'm i'm on the
board and so
yeah i'm wow i'm a big baby so i mean
that would be actually awesome i just
actually feel like i i played it one
time and it's like all the things i love
in a sport you know it's like
fast twitch and touch and and it's that
super athletic and you gotta move yeah i
know i i don't play outside you know
people are like oh you play in the
garden i'm like no we don't like real
batman players don't play outside oh
really yeah you know playing like at a
picnic like that's crazy
okay yeah exactly sorry i didn't mean to
get mad but like yeah whoa
you'd be like hey zach i'm having a
picnic you want to come and say batman
i'm like [ __ ] you
yeah well he really set him off yeah
that's he was so nice up until then
that's what triggered
exactly why you set up a tennis
tournament in the [ __ ] driveway
might as well play football in the pool
yeah [ __ ] [ __ ]
um
uh wow okay badminton i you know makes
me i always want i have a set that i'm
sorry to say this i
occasionally set up in the yard like
something lame during clothing you could
say say i did it
that's fine oh really yeah you play you
play play
yeah
it's fine
um if you could have one snack food for
the rest of your life
what would it be
excuse me oh um
the truth is it'd probably be um
sour cream and onion ruffles potato
chips i would say
if that had
yeah that's just like crack really oh
crack do a whole bag i could do a whole
bag doritos too i could do a whole bag i
can't have them in the house yeah i
can't have them either sometimes my wife
will buy them and i'm like are you
insane bringing that what are you doing
to me yeah
honestly you might as well put the
badminton set outside yeah yeah you just
go go nuts why i don't i don't know what
you're doing
you try to ruin my throat and start
stopping them you gotta
kill them
but you're an addict so you run to the
little crumbs and start licking the
ground it's like you know what you do
you open the bag you eat a few you put
it down oh yeah and then you do some
weird loop around the kitchen and you
end up back there with like one more
yeah yeah you try to hide them but i
i'll put a tight i'll wrap them up put
them behind things yeah a hundred
percent so yeah
i can't have that in the house
uh what is your we we have a question we
asked what's your favorite movie sequel
of all time but i i'm i'm now also just
specifically wondering what your
favorite uh
superhero movie is uh prior to the
you know the kind of newer ones in the
2000s like when you're growing up like a
strict superhero movie
yeah
uh yeah
that's tough um were you up were you
like my coach my favorite sequel of all
time was um
is aliens
oh yeah yeah that's a great sequel
because it's not trying to be the other
movie but it's perfect yeah it's
logically advanced but yeah um yeah i
did like the burton batman
um
you know
i thought michael
i didn't get i was like i'm a dark
knight returns guy
frank miller
and so i was like
i wanted a bigger batman
keaton did a great job but just in my
mind you know reality
yeah although when i was a kid i guess i
saw it when i was 9 10 so to me he was
you know he's wearing the suit so it
kind of worked for me as a kid um yeah
but i that's why i catch stan affleck
because you know he's all he's six he's
six fold he's huge yeah yeah his head is
huge
his head is unbelievably huge
not ego-wise like he's physically if you
take his hat you could like get in a
lake and like use it as a boat it's like
not
yeah he puts it on the final rung i
don't like to take photos with him
because it always looks like he's way
closer to the camera
well my brother you mentioned bradley
cooper my brother and i have a really
funny photo we were with bradley and um
in las vegas and he looks like i was
with another frank here o'donnell uh and
so it was like the three of us and
bradley is towering and also the way the
perspective of it he we look like his
kids
we look like we have a big handsome like
movie star dad yeah it's cool that's
really funny
huge it's like divorced parents you know
and you're like yeah well your cool dad
yeah our cool dad took us for a weekend
in vegas yeah
big brother program
yeah that's what it looks like
uh that's really funny when we were kids
for some reason superman 3 was my
brother watched it religiously like he
wore when good superman fights the bad
superman uh he wore a whole let's you
know the scene the
we and to this day i watch and i'm like
it's still my favorite
it's unbelievably i can't watch that
movie it's crazy
i do love that you love it though that's
amazing yeah i love it um
well
uh aliens is such a good yeah what's
your what's your go to do you ever do
when i imagine you do do karaoke uh what
is what would be your go-to karaoke song
if you were forced a long black veil you
know you know that song by the
chieftains
oh i know the chief yeah i could never
find it on karaoke but oh so it's
perfect it's the only thing if you don't
want to sing karaoke yeah sorry it's a
good one if you have long black veil
i'll do that and they're like
and then like you know some smart ass
might be like well i can play live here
like you guys i'm like ah [ __ ]
uh
you you caught me uh name dropping bon
joey my producer michelle and i were
talking about the episode we did with
bon jovi and um
and he i asked him that question because
we did these are uniform questions and
he was like
no i
i do it for a living i don't
why would i need to go sing that's a
good question it's hilarious yes i think
i remember doing uh you know patrick
wilson can sing really well you know
great like an angel crazy and amy and
amy adams can also sing oh i bet crazy
and you know like you don't
like they're always like let's go do
karaoke you know these are the kind of
people that got to do karaoke yes and
i'm like that's not fun for anyone else
like you got up there and sang and it
was an amazing show
you did a show
and then i get up and it's like a joke
yeah so that's fun for you too right
like yeah you get awesome and then you
get to laugh at me it's like a cool
yeah it just gets any better
so yeah and not only is he because
patrick also has like a kind of a fun
playful yeah so he does it he sings it
well but he also like kind of sells it
and he's like the music man
it's a [ __ ] it's a great show i was like
oh this is like dinner theater suddenly
i'm like yeah but i don't want to
right
it's like a theater where they go like
the show ends and then they go okay now
it's for your turn to get up there yeah
yeah
i'm not in the show am i
right right yeah it's like that's what
was that cheesy uh broadway show they
parody in in uh curvier enthusiasm
like tony and tina's it's like one of
those shows tony and tina's wedding they
blew you up yeah yeah yes
uh who you you were the groomer um
who was uh who was your very first
celebrity crush that you were that you
can remember oh holly hunter
oh yeah for sure
oh yeah i love her and then i put her in
batman versus superman i
didn't want to like and she was awesome
in that i still was crushing on her
during that movie but yeah yeah she's
she's got i love her voice i over voiced
too zach jack yeah
she's crazy
awesome that's great if you listen to
the commentary i like there's a shot of
her sitting at her desk and she's just
like you know cause she's like also just
naturally kind of vascular you know like
she's just got like
she's in great shape
and i'm doing the commentary i'm like
look at her oh my god she's amazing and
i'm like listen to me like quit
i could quit showing your hand spider
that's like horrible
[Laughter]
yeah um
look at that bicep man um
i imagine you do can you do a ben
affleck impression uh you've spent so
much time no i i i i can't do you do any
impressions of anyone that was a good
only holly hunter i think okay okay
um if you had to get a tattoo i don't
know if you have tattoos if you guys
have time
do you yeah oh
are you thinking about getting another
one and what would that be do you think
i'm thinking about getting two um
tattoos of these two byzantine um
two byzantine um
saints ezekiel and elijah because my two
sons my two sons are named ezekiel and
elijah so those are the next two tattoos
i was thinking oh wow okay you know when
you were showing that i saw some on your
hands yeah i got some but i got yeah oh
wow
holy [ __ ] yeah
it's zach is showing me his many tats
beautiful tattoos yeah i got some on my
hair let me just take my shirt off
yeah i mean he's showing me
his testicle tattoos yeah it's really
cool
it's really cool and they're just
tattoos of other testicles it's a barber
pole you should see it
[Laughter]
it's just a guy with a kind of a
like a mushroom haircut holding two eggs
why are you why the zoom man this is
weird
uh it's funny i um
yeah i i
i ca not having seen i can i can imagine
i would have guessed that i should have
guessed that you were a tattoo guy but
did you draw any of them yourself you
seem like no
my friend i have a couple friends that
are tattoo artists and that's dangerous
don't have friends or tattoo artists
because you'll end up okay
who who is that great artist i follow
him on instagram boss logic yeah
yeah boss logic yeah um
he does great stuff don't know why i
mentioned him um
uh what what is your favorite fruit
you know probably
have to be a banana
nothing wrong with that
maybe it's the wrong answer
who no uh who would you want to play
i have this little banana holder in
there yeah i see it here yeah yeah and i
i put that there
you're gonna think i'm really named i i
j
the honor of having jane goodall dr
django on the show and
yeah i put i put that on the show i put
that back there hoping
like she'd see it and i could like
reference it and i totally forgot it was
there until the very end and she's so
sweet she was like i see you have a
chimpanzee right there right behind you
and i and it makes a noise
it's actually cool that you didn't you
let her see it
and she said i was like isn't that funny
and she said
she got kind of sad and she goes oh
that's that actually means it's in
distress
but that's what young chimpanzees yeah
that's the sound they make
yeah that's the sound they make when
they can't get milk from their mother
and then distress and i was like okay
great job great yeah backfired
yeah yeah we mentioned i hate that dude
get out of here
i knew that too i was super freaked out
by it i was testing you oh yeah yeah i
hate that i hate i'm calling the company
that makes these actually that's why i
had it here because i was you know
getting the serial number off the bottom
yeah i could find it's a really popular
company they're going to play into yeah
um
who we met the next one is who would you
want to play you and your bio pick but
you kind of you've answered this yeah i
hope so yeah i mean
now i should be oh okay well i should
get him to direct it probably
i would love a if you have room in the
credits for a special thanks or any sort
of like um what's your favorite uh who's
your favorite
we are usually a simpsons characters but
you seem like you would be more of a
muppets guy like you grew up in that era
um
yeah i do love them either i i and i
love the simpsons actually there was a
simpsons snyder cut reference a couple
weeks ago
that was unrelease the snyder cut which
i thought was hilarious that's funny
that's funny
[Laughter]
you're i'm sure you're going to get that
when you direct something or like
there's a title of something that you've
done do you ever imagine like okay how
could this be spun in a snarky way yeah
like uh
they were like
they had like done this thing where it
said internet troll section and there's
like a few people
funny so they were like it was like
funny hollywood ruins all movies
was one of those signs
and then once there's girls here too one
of the signs there was like a girl
holding it
that's pretty it was pretty funny
i'm sure it featured my my favorites
like secondary like non-homework
characters uh the comic book guys so i
imagine
comic book guy was among them yeah it's
very good yeah i bet um
you must i like that hear from them a
lot like ned no
yeah yeah i love that one ned there's
that one episode where homer um
i think they're skiing and ned's in that
like jumpsuit
yeah he's in that zip type jumpsuit and
he's all like stupid sexy flanders
because he's too he's
he's too handsome he's too hot yeah yeah
he's like kind of ripped and he's got
like he's like a bubble butt his ass
kind of sticks yeah he's got like a
beautiful body i love that he's just
like completely
i remember the first episode you see
that is the one with the uh the
tennessee williams where they're doing
street car march is doing the version of
production of street car
and he rips it he's stella stella he
rips his shirt off he's like it's such a
brilliant choice to make that guy ripped
like undercover it's so good it's so
good
um
dogs are cats
uh dogs uh we have dogs uh you know i do
love cats um i used to have a cat called
picasso and he used to attack me all the
time i loved it and then um
our kids had a french teacher and she
stole it from me so what yeah it's it's
a long story but oh [ __ ] i wish we had
more time
she watched it one time when i went out
of town and she never gave picasso back
back to me okay cool
oh that's very uncool maybe she's
listening yeah um
or maybe picasso is uh beetles are the
stones the rolling stones if you had to
shoot
oh first wow okay yeah yeah you you've
seen them in concert
i've never seen them
i need to
yeah um i really need to i think they
may tour one more time is there a chance
i'm sure they will i would imagine i
don't i can't don't they just won't they
always tour i thought so i thought it
was
you know in perpetuity that they would
be
touring but i think that we're getting
close to a point where they that's why
you got to see it soon i would love to
as well i thought they were supposed to
tour last summer and then covet happened
oh it's that sounds right yeah i think
so anyway because i want my daughter who
is like 10 because i figured
like if she saw the stones live
uh-huh that like the
insane
like when she was my age and being able
to say oh yeah i saw the rolling stones
live totally yeah like the like the the
the span of i know it was unbelievable
isn't that crazy yeah even your father i
would imagine could have seen them live
oh for sure he could have yeah yeah
yeah
yeah he would have like i mean when was
their first hit like in the
60s
yeah
yeah
yeah holy [ __ ]
so seinfeld's on and friends is on is
there a clear one that you guys do
yeah yeah
correct and uh ketchup or mustard final
question you know it depends i gotta go
like ketchup
i'm um
i'm a weird like
ketchup to me is like a farewell it's
like a catch-all
you know
but like if i have i'll put
mayonnaise on french fries
if i have a chance and i'll
mustard and relish on a hot dog
if i have a chance
but ketchup is kind of like yeah it's
non-descript it's like yeah i'm glad
it's here but i'm not gonna
you're not gonna go crazy i'm not gonna
go to the mat for it you know i'm like
thank you for doing this no my pleasure
that was fun really really this was
really fun a huge really big fan of your
work and so i'm glad i got to got to
meet you and i have you sir i have you
ow thanks man uh well you could be in
the movie you'll be in the movie when we
make the snyder cup movie i would love
it okay i'll play i'll play somebody in
the when when bradley's playing you uh
i'll play somebody that hopefully it's
not too insulting yeah you can yeah i'm
trying to think who's like who's
charming and funny
in my group
and like really like overtly sexual yeah
like just like super handsome dudes just
like kind of the ned flanders of the
group like that yeah
hey that's actually a compliment um all
right well we'll workshop somebody yeah
yeah plenty of plenty of characters
thanks man um and uh thank you for all
the work and and for doing this yeah my
pleasure
[Music]
so that happened
it's doing comic book guy
that was the
when it comes to directors one of the
best episodes ever is he your favorite
you said that i think he's the funniest
i think i find him the funniest what did
you think i was um like has happened
often lately on the show that i had a
certain
preconceived idea of
a guest before i heard them because i
didn't yeah i had never really heard him
either had i so i
was under i was under the impression
that he may have come across as being
a little difficult to talk about yes
yeah kind of like full of themselves
like yeah some directors and be sure i
want to mention you know both of you
would think zack snyder would have been
more bombastic and arrogant than he came
than he was yeah like really
cocky yeah
maybe assuming i know just because but
he wasn't at all he was i know he was
just so down to earth and accessible i
did i knew so little about zach that i
just you right i did i am ashamed that i
thought he might be difficult i know not
even difficult just like not that
accessible he was so like he didn't want
to talk like i s i was surprised for
example that he was so candid
about talking about his start and he
came up and his family i thought he'd be
more like let's talk about the movie i'm
here oh my god i know kind of guy
exactly and he wasn't he was so open and
funny and accessible to the point where
he even said i often don't know what i'm
doing like i rely on other people
to help me make the best thing and i
believed him when he said that i feel
like you hit it off with him pretty well
and obviously it would be amazing if he
wanted to put you in a movie someday or
if he wanted to be in one of our movies
that would be great too uh but what if
he let you
or and me maybe now oh shadow shadow
here that's a great i just follow him
around and so we could we would pick up
so it would be like film school oh my
god you know we'd be good good shadows
too yeah we stay out of people's ways
we're very apologetic yeah
yeah i'd even like be kind of a gopher
i'd go run i'd get him stuff if he
needed it i'd be like a shadow slash
that would be fun i you know that'd be
fun he's so laid-back and easy to talk
to that like i sort of forgot that he
was this like powerful director that
could like
you know that could like really help my
acting career and then when he said that
i was like hahaha no but wait really can
i that'd be and then the modest part of
you is like i'll just like walk in the
background and like fart i know i kind
of mean that though our friend kat coyer
was directing she-hulk a big the big
marvel
show and um
i said that to her and i sort of meant
it i mean i don't know if i'd it would
be that satisfying to just fart in the
background but because that's the ticket
getting into the uh a universe either
the mcu or the dcu some universe yeah
not the and right now we're in the icu
the independent cinematic universe yes
the lbs cu the low budgets
when he talked about directing a micro
budget movie in south america
i don't know what he thinks micro budget
is well he probably like 25 million i'm
sure he referred to dawn of the dead as
like uh he's like well that was really
and i know i because i remember when
that they were auditioned i remember
seeing that on the that was like a i
think i guess a 10 million dollar movie
oh sure which to us would be i mean
[ __ ]
huge crazy i wonder if he wants to
direct a comedy yeah that's he's funny
he is funny i know that he's not only
funny he seems to really enjoy funny
things yes i love that about him that he
would keep the joke going because i'm
usually that guy i mean like and my
friends the people that i gravitate
toward are it's like if there is a funny
little nugget you wanna
i guess i'm friends with a lot of hams
you wanna like milk it of course you
wanna like ring it for all of its comedy
potential right i like how into
badminton he is it wasn't that crazy
that he want to the point where he won't
play outside i know he's not computer
i will not play ping pong outside and
often at parties and stuff
there when there's a ping pong table it
you'll be able to be outside yeah but i
never want to play outside aren't most
party ping-pong situations like beer
pong
no it was that's just the parties i've
gone through
i mean were you 21.
i haven't been to one in a while but you
know i i always get really nervous
playing a flip cup
i played a bunch and like of course yeah
i get re i find myself you don't want to
be the guy in the team holding everybody
up it's a it's a very high stakes yeah
it can get plays on my guilt and like so
i get like
i get like shaky and nervous
i was never great at flipkart and when
you're not good at it it's really rev
it's like and everyone's yelling on your
team
yeah yeah yeah dude no software and then
they obviously advise you oh god i hate
flipkart i'm getting like
getting nervous
yeah um he does look like bradley cooper
doesn't he he does yeah i uh he's funny
he was kind of teasing himself but but
he actually does i was like yeah
that makes sense i don't know who else
would play him like
now it's the actor that i the only actor
i can think of to play him and that
would make it cool legitimately i think
he was sort of joking about that i think
maybe not but it would make a cool story
they're doing the godfather like that
yeah i mean
that's the god the godfather is also i
mean yeah well the godfather itself is
is a classic i know it's tough to
compare it to a movie that just came out
exactly but in terms of the fandom and
the scale of it yeah
i would say they're
comparable and and the drama the
dramatic element of like how this one
big director took over and the fans were
yeah it's pretty good make it cool i'll
tell you what there's a fan base for it
yeah that's true a lot of people would
see it that's true and you could
probably do it like a lower budget thing
and you can make it more comedic that's
the thing i keep thinking about since
you said that um him doing a comedy he
he i'd be so curious uh it's funny
because like a lot of his those
superhero movies
what joss whedon wanted tried to put
into it i think with a lot of people who
showed up on set and the bloggers that
he mentioned they wanted to see more
joking can't be stuff because like the
earlier dc certainly superman stuff and
even batman earlier batman was like a
little
lighter yeah definitely lighter
like jack nicholson as the joker was
like this town needs an enema and like
yeah see i would say i
i kind of disagree because i think jack
that jack nicholson joker is well he's
so heavy i mean he's scary
yeah just because the performance but
there's some lines and like yeah and you
if you remember the um
he's like the gangsters the like uh his
his what do you call thugs
yeah i think that's what they're
actually called in the movie thugs yeah
so like um that guy bob
really great actor but i think he plays
bob
they all they like spray paint they're
like really like
early 90s like late 80s like fluorescent
colors there's something kind of like
clownish about them yeah they're like
kind of
silly
especially in when you consider compare
them to the christopher nolan oh my god
i really like batman begins i think it's
2005. but i remember thinking this is
absolutely nothing like any of the
superhero movies but i watched growing
up yeah but it was so cool because it
was so cool like because batman
because i got into the frank miller uh
graphic novel the frank miller batman
was uh dark knight was like it was that
it was like darker colors and and themes
and more graphic like more violent um so
it's truer to that but like the
but like i didn't know that kind of
superman i remember mom got us the
superman when superman died when they
were trying to
um she got us all those comic books of
uh because she thought they'd be worth
something
and i never unpacked it in the packaging
i wonder how much it's worth now
probably nothing because everyone got it
because it was all over the news and i
was like yeah um but that
it's still hard i i really
there's some such cool parts of those uh
zack snyder superman's but i i see when
i he kind of laughed at me for watching
this superman 3
for enjoying that superman and i
that's just what i knew growing up that
was my superman so it's hard now to see
like
henry not hard but it's like when henry
cavill's like really brooding and that
superman is not as familiar to me of
course yeah i mean to me when i think
superman i i will always think
christopher reeve you know always
god was he good
and those movies were
lighter and campier but they also had
darker elements they did and those were
the parts i tended to like the most i
didn't really like the silly things as
much yeah i'm thinking of yeah because
gene hackman was like definitely an
imposing
but he had funny stuff with news it was
a great balance yeah great funny but
also scary and then miss tessmacher oh
man
great
anyway um but the new version yes the
justice league is
it it definitely does justice to it
but i'm excited to see the uh the true
if the if the movie is anything
close to as cool as the trailer it's a
little longer it's a little longer i
think i'm gonna like it a lot it looks
really cool as does army of the dead
which comes out uh i think end of may on
netflix that looks so cool and and also
looks a little bit more um like his dawn
of the dead stuff which was there there
was a lot of humor in it there was uh
playful
elements um and of starring former life
is short guest friend of the show dave
bautista oh right uh so check that out
and uh check out justice league let's
read a letter okay
is there something else no
from lindsay
i don't know why i want to pronounce
that lindsay it's lindsey lindsay yeah
you want to pronounce that lindsay i
just saw it that way it's l-i-n-d-s-a-y
but it's lindsay
lindsay
lindsey kebbel kimball
subject who chooses the letters to be
read at the end
who chooses the letters to be right at
the end
is that the subject yeah oh
uh hello justin and christian i love the
podcast and the conversations at the
beginning and especially the end with
christian
hey yes oh i thought you would say
thanks
that's a weird
nerdy reaction yes
score
uh back to lindsay i am really curious
who chooses the letters that make it on
at the end of the show i have noticed
two things
quite a few letters are from canada
it's true
uh sorry
uh which i am also a proud canadian i
live on vancouver island oh [ __ ] i heard
that's beautiful vancouver i've never
been to vancouver oh it's so cool
vancouver island great chinese food
really great dumplings some of the best
yeah
uh let me know if you want to back to
lindsay let me know if you want to know
the best places to go camping here i do
with your new rad van once the pandemic
ends and the borders reopen that's right
the borders are can you not get into
canada now i don't know uh this island
has some of the most beautiful places
yeah i've heard lindsay that's cool the
other thing i have noticed is that many
of the letters are written by people who
have names that span all genders
it's a funny way to say that i love how
you never know if you should be saying
her or him or even they or them
that's true
i
i won't confuse you as i have met at
least one very attractive male named
lindsay
uh probably not graham not lindsey
graham
thinking what other lindsay lindsey
buckingham oh yeah
he was attractive
he was a maniac but i don't think
lindsey graham is unattractive no he's
he's uh he's toothy
he is he i guess if you isolate it he
has kind of nice eyes and lips he has a
nice face i think he does he's a little
bit like um you know who he reminds me
of his
principal skinner
he's got kind of like a little bit
doesn't sound like that he sounds a
little bit more like corky saint claire
yeah um i will sign my now i want to
talk like i will sign my letter with my
pronouns says lindsay
okay thank you lindsay uh back to
lindsay thanks for bringing us a fun
entertaining and thoughtful lindsay
might be a man still oh yeah
i just peaked so i know what lindsay is
oh you do okay
i can't i have no patience
why couldn't i have waited that would
have been a fun review you can't control
what your eyes do sometimes it was right
there it's so close right there
it's so close to the end uh as is our
show right now uh thanks okay uh thank
you lindsey for that compliment um p.s
if i had to pick only one sport to watch
from now on it would have to be
she's just the emoji of hockey first and
then says hockey just to clarify it so
because that could be uh yeah field
hockey or what else could that be like
curling
uh i don't think that could be curling
yeah it could only be hockey okay it's a
punk and a hockey stick yeah um
uh in parentheses this was a question
you and christian were debating on the
most recent show oh right what sport we
would want to watch
uh lindsay kimball
uh she
lindsey's a she her okay thank you
lindsey for writing and i
somewhat disagree about the hockey and
and mostly because we didn't grow up
with watching it well it's not for you
to disagree that's her thing i know um
uh yeah it's a bummer that they're no
would you rathers but um
would you rather so would you rather
watch hockey or soccer i'd rather watch
hockey professional than soccer yeah oh
i definitely would it's beautiful with
the gliding and i have friends who are
obsessed with soccer and and their
favorite sport i've never been able to
get into it i know it seems boring it
also brings back really bad memories of
when i play because we we played on rec
leagues here in our hometown fairfield
fairfield and um
i used to i have clear memories of like
being in the gold being a goalie
and praying to god that the ball
wouldn't get kicked to me this is part
of your revisionist history of
of being an awkward no not that i was
awkward you were so good at sports as a
kid i was good i just was i felt such
pressure and like the thought of letting
everyone down like because the few times
you had a lot of guilt as a kid
yeah yeah i guess maybe that's what it
is that's all it is you were good at
sports yeah you were small what sport
was i we were talking about oh badminton
how how um zach wants to play back
he made me want to try it again i
haven't played batman batman badminton
in years but i always liked playing and
i was good at floor hockey
i wasn't great at floor hockey um is it
getting to the point where it's who
cares time
that
uh
okay well
uh speaking of zach thanks uh hope he's
listening not speaking of who cares no
no no that was a bad segue
uh no we care about zach and uh we thank
him for being on the show because he was
god what a nice surprise and maybe he'll
cast you someday well
a huge movie oh don't think i haven't
thought that um yeah come on i'll i'll
fart in the background i'll do something
fun um
i'll be an easter egg
is that arrogant to think that i could
be you'll actually be an easter egg
you'll dress up as an easter egg
yeah uh literally
and uh thanks to lindsay campbell and
all the canadians yes thank you and oh
and to answer your question uh michelle
miesh
lanz picks out the letters oh yeah she
sends uh she sends us letters that's
right and we have a little system here
we just got a new printer not to brag
well actually we got a printer because
we haven't had one for a while and uh
christian will then just kind of sort
through the view that she's narrowed
down and then he'll send it right and
the printer is right behind me and i try
to
send one without reading it myself um i
i get it i got a sense of you know the
length and yeah you know that kind of oh
that's cool and this is probably clear
to everyone but i definitely don't read
them that's true as well yeah so you can
hear that as i'm stumbling through
sometimes okay so speaking of something
stumbling through um thank you everyone
and thanks to zach and go check out you
know he's got these little indie movies
that like need your help they need you
to choose also if you want to take a
break from his fine work uh you should
watch
yes our fine work no
a reality show called
kings of pain yes yeah on the history
channel and 90 day fiance oh man we're
really into 90 day fiance
and if for no other reason if you're
really into the show we're probably
going to run out of things other things
to talk about so we'll probably be
talking about 90 day fiance soon because
that's kind of yeah so look forward to
that and uh look forward to next week's
show hopefully oh yeah hopefully
i mean please listen no no i thought you
were saying like there might not be a
show oh no there will be yes uh
hopefully unless the world unless
there's some kind of zack snyder uh
apocalyptic all right yeah okay we'll
see you next
could be a week
life could be a dream
life is short is hosted by me justin
long it's co-hosted and produced by
i forget christian oh that's right and
megan monaco oh that's right and the
senior producer remind me again who it
is michelle miesh lance oh and there's
an audio engineer don't tell me who it
is sergio enriquez yeah and okay don't
tell me this one but there's an
executive producer and i think his name
is marshall
louie right four oh it's a company
that's like dundery or dunder mifflin
[Music]
do you do women ever use that expression
about men have you noticed
before but but it's a little women's
work man yeah i guess it's a little
nerdy to use yeah i guess i don't use
this i know
she's my crafty name that's true
it's what nerds say about
towards you well you can use it to me
but because it's it's really a positive
term i never realized how it's like it's
not
it's like so i can't like yeah she's my
weakness she makes me you know
i never realized how interwoven that was
um superman's like aggression and his
horniness
i never got predatory
i never saw that as a kid i never that
never
or maybe it's in the last couple of
years because you know like this down to
the patriarchy i kind of remember being
let down like sensitive too yeah
maybe i i kind of remember being let
down that he i knew it was the same
person was like clark kent and superman
and they had such a like chased like
sweet thing going on with lana what's
your name uh a lot of like monoling
i think
you